Speaker 1: Let's go next to why don't we go
now to Jack?
Is it Jess or Jessie from North Carolina?
It's kind of cut off.
Speaker 3: Josiah as a matter of fact, josiah.
Speaker 1: Welcome, josiah.
Speaker 3: I appreciate it.
David.
Hey, I got a question, especially in light
of the last night's debate between Oz and
Fetterman.
Yes.
Speaker 1: Right.
Speaker 3: Or was it not last night?
Speaker 1: Well, you know, it's Friday.
Today.
It's Friday today.
Speaker 3: True.
Touché.
I got thinking about, you know, we're seeing
obviously the the polls change to the detriment
of Democrats.
You've been commenting on this on your shows.
And I keep going back to the double standards
to which I feel that Democrats are held to,
not just by conservatives, but also by centrist
moderates and people on the left.
Yeah.
In terms of performance and substance.
And I was on Twitter and I was seeing like
all the headlines from people who would be
considered, quote unquote, liberal or mainstream
journalists, which are perceived to have a
liberal bias.
And they were ravaging Fetterman for his performance,
even though, you know, his communication issues,
as far as we know, are just it's temporary
aphasia.
It's a stroke induced speech impediment.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I don't know how temporary
it is, to be totally honest, but it's not
cognitive.
I mean, he remembered all the facts.
He remembered all the points.
He understood his position and those of Mehmet
Oz.
I don't know if it's temporary, but it's certainly
it's only a speech thing.
That's absolutely the case.
Speaker 3: And fair enough.
It may it may very well not be transient.
But I got thinking about it and I'm like,
the GOP has been fielding and successfully
electing terrible communicators who, as far
as we know, don't have a medical basis like
W Bush and Palin and Trump and Gosar and GREENE.
Why is it that everybody, not just conservatives,
but everybody, seems to hold Democrats to
a higher standard of performance and style
and substance in terms of politicking and
messaging and debate?
And is there anything that we can do as people
who want Democrats to take power to stop contributing
to that double standard?
Speaker 1: I don't know what we can do to
stop contributing to it.
You know, you're asking me why?
Because they're hypocrites, right?
I don't know how to answer it any more clearly.
You know, Herschel Walker, as far as we know,
didn't have a stroke.
It's not been acknowledged that he has CTE
from playing football and he makes less sense
than Fetterman.
Right.
Fetterman had a speech issue, but he at least
communicated policy and understands the issues
and stuck to the issue that was being discussed,
etc., etc..
They say Fetterman should have dropped out.
Bah bah bah bah bah.
And they say any criticism of Herschel Walker
is racism, for example, or something like
that.
I don't know what we can do to stop them being
hypocrites, but that's fundamentally what
this is.
Speaker 3: Do you agree, though?
Because I guess I don't see it just as an
us versus them.
I feel that that people who would nominally
be considered, quote unquote liberal are quote
unquote, you know, like like there's the perception
that the mainstream media that The New York
Times, that CNN has a liberal bias.
And I probably agree that most New York Times
and CNN journalists, I would expect, would
vote Democrat, but they, I feel, hold Democrats
to higher performative and substantive standards
than Republicans as well.
Because, again, if if the metric is this person's
a poor communicator, therefore they should
drop out of the race, then who on earth could
the Republican Party ever field?
Yeah.
W Bush.
Palin.
Trump.
So?
So, do you agree?
I guess you agree that it's not just conservatives
holding Democrats to a higher standard of
ideology?
Speaker 1: I do agree.
And part of it is, I mean, it's a good thing
that we have higher standards, right?
Trump would never have won the Democratic
primary in 2016.
He won the Republican primary because we have
higher, higher standards than they do.
And that's a good thing.
In a lot of cases, it starts to become not
so good if it contributes to more of these
right wing lunatics getting elected.
Speaker 3: I agree.
Okay.
Well, I appreciate it.
I'm glad.
At least we were there's some sort of consensus
and I appreciate your coverage on all this.
Keep going.
Speaker 1: Thank you so much.
Very much.
Appreciate the call.
Let's go to Dylan from Tijuana.
Dylan, welcome.
Speaker 3: When I was there, David got with
us.
The Minister.
Speaker 1: Can I tell you something that drives
me nuts about how Americans pronounce the
name of the of the city or in.
Speaker 3: Oh, my God.
Me too.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
They say, oh, you know, I went from San Diego
to Tijuana and I'm like, Oh, first of all.
Speaker 3: No.
Where are you?
Speaker 1: Where are you getting some of these
additional syllables?
It doesn't make any sense, Tia.
Like the words for aunt, it's Tijuana.
That's it, guys, please.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I.
Speaker 1: Know.
All right, Dylan, go ahead, please.
I'm sorry.
Speaker 3: Bye.
My question for you is, how screwed do you
think?
Do you think people are in the Colorado River
basin like L.A., Las Vegas, Phenix, San Diego
and Tijuana for water scarcity in the future?
Speaker 1: Oh.
Listen, here's the thing about it.
I don't want to.
Okay, let's see.
How can I.
How can I back this up?
One of the things that sometimes happens in
any kind of climate change discussion is people
will start to say, hey, listen, I agree there's
a problem.
I agree if nothing changes, it'll be a disaster.
But I'm confident that engineering and ingenuity
will figure out a solution before it really
becomes a problem.
And I think that that's very, very dangerous
thinking because we should be trying to figure
things out, but we should also be changing
our behavior and our consumption and all these
different things.
On the issue of water.
I actually am more confident that science
and technology is going to figure out a solution
in that part of the country.
But I still think that water usage and water
rights, which are a really controversial thing
in California and in that area, need to be
kind of rethought from the ground up anyway,
even though, based on what I'm reading about
water technology, it's probably all going
to work out okay.
Although there may be irreversible changes
to the fertility of certain parts of those
states as climate changes and water becomes
more scarce.
Not drinking water, but but sort of groundwater
is, as the case may be.
So that's that's a really complicated issue.
Speaker 3: Yeah.
And here in Tijuana with it's happened a couple
of times this year and several times last
year where we'll have tens of thousands of
people without water because they're making
repairs to the to the water lines, supposedly
for, you know, better efficiency and better
management, stuff like that, that I go out
and drive in the streets of Tijuana and there's
just these large leaks, just, you know, roads
are wet and it's a rainy day because.
Yeah.
So I as a consumer in general, on these climate
change things, I'm tired of being blamed for
my individual choices when it's the large
government authorities and large industries
that are really, really messing up.
Speaker 1: It's like the thing about straws,
you know, and it's like, wait, hold on a second,
let's back up a little bit.
Or, you know, I took a seven instead of a
five minute shower.
But look at the almond and avocado growers
and how they're, you know, using ungodly amounts
of water.
Yeah, no, I totally know what you mean.
The drops in the bucket.
Speaker 3: Exactly right.
Well, I really appreciate you coming down
coming down to our side of the border.
And if you're ever in Tijuana, hit me up.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So, like, what are the what are the best tacos
in Tijuana?
Speaker 3: The tacos you're eating at the
time.
Oh, okay.
Speaker 1: They're all.
They're all good.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I will say one thing.
In Tijuana, we have a slight regional variation
on some other border.
Alabama in Tijuana mean something different
from the rest of the country.
The rest of the country and the U.S. will
call it all bastards.
But we have our own little kind of twist,
regional twist on it.
So I highly recommend Alabama.
Speaker 1: That's that's a fair recommendation.
Have you had Americans go down and ask about
tacos?
Have you heard that pronunciation before?
Speaker 3: Are you just like asking the credits,
don't you, Dave?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I've heard everything.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: Yeah, no, I.
The other day, a friend of mine said tacos,
and I was like, What is happening?
Speaker 3: Yeah.
Speaker 1: Anyway, all right.
Well, thank you for the call.
I appreciate it.
Speaker 3: We're just going to just have.
Speaker 1: You all, Mindy.
All right.
Let's take a very, very short break if you're
holding.
Stay on, because we're going right back to
the phones in a moment.